hey guys welcome to awesome build
unfortunately this week I don't have
time to actually build anything for you
guys I've got a bunch of big practice
going on in the studio this week and
it's the holidays so things are a little
busy but I thought it'd be a great
opportunity to field some questions that
you guys have left in the comments so I
think we'll just stay warm and sit
around by the Christmas tree and answer
some questions let's go
[Music]
but one of the common questions I get is
where did I learn how to do the stuff
that I do did I go to school did I have
an apprenticeship and the answer is no I
did go to film school back in the mid
90s at Columbia College and I studied
film and animation which is kind of I
had already done a little bit of
stop-motion animation in high school and
some cel animation in high school and
that was kind of propelled me to go to
college and study it further and getting
into that aspect of it I really was into
stop-motion animation and building
puppets and I thought that that would be
maybe what I did but I was also into
acting and straight up filmmaking so I
would get involved in other people's
projects or I was starting my own
projects and often the one thing that we
needed was props or costumes or set
pieces and I always felt that those
things were very important helping to
tell a story so I generally would just
take those things upon myself to either
get those props or acquire them or if I
couldn't find them to make them somehow
so part of it was out of an interest to
do it and part of it was out of
necessity I guess I often took jobs in
maintenance and construction and odd
jobs here and there doing different
maintenance and so all those different
elements work
a little bit electrical a little bit in
plumbing a little bit in HVAC a little
bit of construction and building things
so all of those different elements over
the years have been great resources to
pull from and I could also put that into
the art of creating sets and sculpting
things and making effects I've also
always just had a real interest in
practical effects and I've always
thought that the costumes and props and
sets really help tell the story and it
also helps actors and filmmakers tell
their story if the things around them
make them feel like they're immersed
within that world so what is the one
thing that I'm most proud of that I made
either for Channel awesome or personal I
would say all of the work that we did
for the Mad Max fury road review is
probably my favorite I was really happy
with the way the Amorim Joe masks came
out I was very pleased with the way that
Tamra's curiosa costume came together in
the furiosa arm all of those elements I
had to build rather quickly with very
limited resources and despite that I
felt like they came out really well I
was happy with the way they turned out
and when Rob put on that mask or when
Tamra got into that costume and had the
arm and stuff on I know that it made
them feel like the character and that is
very gratifying when I know I can build
something or make something for an actor
or actress that helps them morph into
that role or feel empowered or feel more
like that character then I feel like
I've done my job
and so that part is always very
satisfying and rewarding I am NOT
Bootsie and I am not related to Bootsie
nor have I ever met Bootsie so I hope
that answers that question what the hell
is with that giant wall of weapons well
I have to confess the wall of weapons
belongs to me when we opened the studio
and I was hired on full-time I had quite
a bit of props and costumes
and materials that I had accumulated
over 1516 years worth of working on
other projects and other productions and
how I acquired all of that stuff very
often when I work for another low-budget
production they would need a prop guy or
costume or makeup or something like that
I would generally do it pro bono but one
of my stipulations was I would just keep
whatever props that I acquired or made
for that production so over the years of
working on my home projects and other
people's projects I acquired quite an
inventory of props and costumes and
stuff when we first moved in here
probably about 85 to 90% of the costumes
and props and helmets and boots and
materials and stuff like that belonged
to me and I brought them in since we've
been here for several years jail awesome
has acquired a ton of stuff so it's kind
of been a marriage of a lot of the props
and stuff like that I've brought in and
stuff that channel awesome has acquired
a lot of you have commented on my
t-shirts and where do I get my t-shirts
work and you get them actually most of
the t-shirts that I wear on the show are
from tee fury comm or from shirt punch
but most of them come from tee fury and
or a few that come from counterculture
and one or two that I've made myself so
if you're interested in getting some
cool t-shirts like the ones I have worn
on the show go to the links below
finally a lot of you have inquired as to
why I wear the black armband in so many
of my builds well actually there's no
big secret it's because I have
epicondylitis which is just a fancy way
of saying I have tennis elbow but I
don't play tennis
but wearing the band actually helps
alleviate some of the stress and
discomfort that I feel so mystery solved
that is your gift Merry Christmas
just kidding all kidding aside I just
want to take another minute to say how
grateful I am to all of you guys for
watching and supporting the show it's
the only reason why I do it each week is
because you guys keep watching so the
show will return in the new year so some
of you may or may not know in addition
to building props and stuff for Doug and
doing the awesome builds I also cook
Purdue's awesome comics with Walter
Benedict and I help him film top 5 and I
also basically manage the studio and so
I've been doing a lot of work around the
studio to kind of help organize and
rearrange and make it run and be a
little bit more efficient and smooth
that has actually been a big project and
it's been kind of an ongoing project
ever since we moved in here especially
in the last few weeks months I've put a
lot of work into organizing and
rearranging and building the studio so
that it runs a little bit more smoothly
and things are a little bit more
efficient and so that's been a huge
project that I've been kind of doing in
my spare time once things are kind of
finalized and situated I will do a
studio tour and we can do kind of a
walkthrough and I'll show you guys sort
of all of the little nooks and crannies
and ins out of channel awesome studios
so look forward to that in the new year
so once again I just wanted to say how
grateful I am to all of you for watching
and supporting the show it really means
a lot
I'm so glad you guys have enjoyed it so
far and I hope that going into the new
year I've got a lot of new fun cool
projects that you guys will enjoy so
stay tuned for those happy holidays have
a safe holiday Merry Christmas
Cheers
[Music]
you